at this important time for our country
they need stability uncertainty provided
by the government and that's what I've
been doing today putting together a
cabinet that reflects the wealth of
talent and experience across the
Conservative Party a cabinet that will
get on with the job of government that's
about delivering a successful brexit
negotiations and those negotiations
start in a week's time but it's also
about ensuring we're dealing with some
of the social issues that we see in our
country so tackling issues around mental
health ensuring we have proper technical
education for young people tackling the
housing crisis this is what my cabinet
this is what my government will be
getting on and doing and Prime Minister
just one question or two the big news
today obviously is the return of Michael
Gove to your cabinet are you now in a
situation where you're so weakened by
that snap election that you have no
choice but to put influential
adversaries at the oar top table proof
in the words of George Osborne that
you're a dead woman walk in what I've
done today is seen people from across
the party accepting the invitation to be
in my cabinet and crucially I've brought
in talent from across the whole of the
Conservative Party
I believe that's important this is a
government that is going to be governing
for everyone we want a country that
works for everyone bringing that talent
together to ensure that we can get on
with the job of delivering a successful
brexit but also deal with some of the
challenges that people see in their
everyday lives like dealing with the
housing need for more housing like
ensuring that we have a proper mental
health legislation that is going to
support people and providing that
technical education for young people I'm
pleased that people from across the
party have agreed to serve in my cabinet
and we're going to be getting on with
the job of government and just one more
thing if you don't mind Prime Minister
it's obviously been a very difficult few
days for you both personally I would
imagine and politically how are you
feeling I imagine you're feeling rather
shell-shocked what I'm feeling is that
actually there is a job to be done and I
think what the public want is to ensure
that the government is getting on with
that job and I've pointed cabinet
members
ministers today I'll be meeting with my
cabinet tomorrow on Tuesday I will be
going to France for meetings with
president macron these are important in
getting on with our preparations for the
brexit negotiations but also dealing
with the challenges that people see in
their everyday lives this is a
government that's getting on with work
we need to do to ensure that we are
being a government that will govern for
everyone that we see opportunity across
the country that we see people able to
make the most of their lives this is a
government getting on with the job
thank you just one more thing quickly in
terms of your intentions for number turn
some of your colleagues have been
suggesting that you might be a caretaker
Prime Minister just to be clear for the
record do you intend to serve a full
term I said and during the election
campaign that if we elected I would
intend to serve a full term but what I'm
doing now is actually getting on with
the immediate job and I think that's
what's important I think that's what the
public would expect they want to see
government providing that certainty it's
and stability at what is a critical time
for the country the brexit negotiations
start in just a week we need to get
those right and make a success of it but
there are other issues that we need to
address in our country we've been
listening to voters and that's what we
will be doing